[Music]
hey guys welcome to another episode of
my podcast
[Music]
congratulations
oh dude yeah man
okay another episode
i thought we'd stop after four episodes
but we keep going
and it is freaking on dude
uh let's start off with
uh thank you and i'm i
love that you guys listen to this
podcast and it
i like doing it i like doing this
podcast
and before i get into uh
liking and subscribing i want to tell
you right now
that i your boy started [ __ ] cutting
his own hair you know that i've been
cutting my own hair
for about a year now and i'm getting
good at it
and that's it and that's that dude but
i'm getting really good at cutting my
hair
and i did it again and he did it again
dude and it's the best cut he's given
himself
and now i i don't say that to brag
it's a little bit braggy but it's really
hard to get the back
but i got good at getting the back i was
good at doing the sides the sides are
easy
the front a little less easier than the
sides
because you get nervous when you do the
front i get nervous when i do the front
because you can't take back the front
dude
you cannot take back the front can't
take back the sides either
we can hide the sides can't hide the
front can you
if you go oops bangs you go oops bangs
right it's like not it's not
that's why it's just tough man so i did
it and i cut the [ __ ] back and this
time i took my cell phone
and i i looked at the back and i looked
in the mirror and i cut it like this it
was like a whole [ __ ] cool tom cruise
movie doing it
but only in like his life isn't that
cool it's like a
tom cruise [ __ ]
movie where at the end of the movie then
he gets retired and then that's what
he's doing he's still using all the
technology and gadgets to cut his own
hair
but um yeah so i [ __ ] rock at cutting
my
own hair and you guys should cut your
own hair too because you don't need hair
cutters
it's a [ __ ] uh scam dude
you just sit in those chairs and they
cut cut takes a long time you got to
drive by the time you're done
it's been two two and a half hours
chicks need it i know we've been through
this before we don't need to talk about
it anymore but you know what dude
i'm so sick of [ __ ] having people
watch this show and not
[ __ ] absolutely destroying that
subscribe button
you guys roll up and put out a [ __ ]
hit
on that subscribe button i swear to god
put out a [ __ ] hit on that subscribe
button don't smash that
like don't smash that subscribe button
don't
dis just [ __ ] absolutely roll up in a
humvee
somebody took my humvee dude that was
one of the parts in
the rock the movie the rock where uh
the guy there there's one part there's
one he's his only line
in the rock is somebody took my humvee
he's talking to the valet guy and it was
[ __ ] sean connery or nicholas cage
and me and the girl that i took the
movie to when i was 16
we [ __ ] laughed so hard at that and
we always used to say that to each other
and then she broke up with me and
started dating my best friend
and i [ __ ] uh i didn't like it at all
it really made me very upset but it's
all good now dude
cause i'm 41 and i forgive them
and so somebody took my humvee and uh
but what was i even [ __ ] talking
about oh yeah dude so absolutely roll up
and [ __ ]
roll up with the homies on some [ __ ]
humvee [ __ ] and just
just [ __ ] absolutely destroy that
subscribe button and dude like
absolutely [ __ ] what was the other
one i was gonna say god damn it i have a
[ __ ]
i have i need to start drinking some
ginkgo biloba i need to
start drinking some ginkgo biloba
because i was going to say
[ __ ] something really good for the
like button but now i just got to go
back to [ __ ] my brain and just get
lucy goosey and be like put a [ __ ]
headlock on that like button dude
you know what seriously put a headlock
on that like button in all seriousness
if you're not liking the videos and
you're not subscribing to the videos
if you're not rolling up and [ __ ]
call the avengers on that like button
that's what i wanted to [ __ ] say
yeah he remembered dude i just had to
get back into the swing of the
dude call the avengers on that [ __ ]
like button man and and
and have them save the day on that
[ __ ] like button [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] out there
yeah smash that like button hey
everybody [ __ ] hit that like button
don't forget to subscribe to each
nope no no no no
and above all dude make friends in the
goddamn comments
if you're watching you're commenting if
you're not commenting you ain't living
dude
there was a time and place where i
[ __ ] didn't i didn't even leave
i i didn't even leave any [ __ ]
comments because i thought it was just
for [ __ ] nerdwells
and crazy [ __ ] but it's not
dude leaving comments is for everybody
yeah
dude so call the avengers on that like
button absolutely roll up in some
[ __ ] humvees
and destroy that subscribe button and
uh make friends in the comments man
just comment something like yeah pretty
good i like the one part then the other
person's like man my favorite part is
this was like oh this guy's not funny oh
and then just [ __ ] take each other
out to dinner dude
and check out that horizontal mambo
um so it's good dude it's all good
it's all good i love this [ __ ] dude this
[ __ ] was making
me laugh this [ __ ] was making
me i put up a [ __ ] first of all wait
hold on before i even get into it
i put up a joke a a tick tock on joe
biden
and so i was making fun of him i was
making fun of him whatever let's
actually watch that video
let's watch that video dude guess what
crush economy
guess what cross economy so drunk
joe biden grows the
economy that's what i'm going to put in
and they're not gonna even [ __ ] have
it
okay wait actually it's here so all good
first thing that came up oh no it's
[ __ ] daily.com
guess what joe biden's economy grows on
tick tock i i don't give a [ __ ]
i just want the the video dude anyway he
does that
and it makes me laugh so hard and then i
put it on my thing for the light for the
new life rips
hoodies that [ __ ] we re-upped okay
we're reloading and uh we we re-upped it
and we put more into production because
those [ __ ] sold like hotcakes
and i put a [ __ ] life rips hat on joe
biden and i and i put it up and guess
what's good for the economy or whatever
the [ __ ]
and everyone was like h3 already did
that dude i don't i'm not watching
podcasts okay
and and and i'm not i don't watch
podcasts
that's it whether or not they're friends
of mine i don't watch podcasts if
they're not friends of mine i'm not
going to watch podcasts if they are
friends of mine [ __ ] i watch a
podcast
i talk to them i'm not watching or not
watching i'm not i'm not watching
podcasts
i'm not doing that i don't do that [ __ ]
people are like oh you you ripped it off
of the [ __ ] thing dude i don't know
oh they did it too yeah dude
so um i don't know if they they did the
same thing i actually don't even i still
don't know but
people a few people were like h3 did you
see h3 and i'm like
i didn't i don't watch podcasts i i
don't watch podcasts
i don't even watch [ __ ] this podcast
and and and when i do
i i don't even want to have to watch
this podcast and now i do because
there's lots of
edits and cuts and [ __ ] and the [ __ ]
and to put the uh the pictures in it and
i haven't get rid of kills that
uh it kills that [ __ ] and i don't i i
don't like having to watch it but then
when i do i really laugh because here's
the thing dude and
let me let me tell you this i do this
podcast and
i i think i'm funny and and you know i
think i'm funny because i laugh at my
own jokes a lot and i do that
in a very genuine manner because i think
it's funny okay and a lot of times i'm
figuring the [ __ ] out in my head as i'm
talking about it
and i'm starting to laugh before i say
it because i'm like oh i can't wait to
say this
because this is going to be funny and
it's like someone else said it all right
so what happens is i talk [ __ ] out
my ass in this podcast
and i do funny [ __ ] and then
when they recut it when they put the the
graphics in and [ __ ] and ivan gets rid
of his like here
and sends me the [ __ ] five days later
i get to watch it and i forgot
everything and i get to see it again and
i sit back and i'm like
that's the [ __ ] dude yeah man
i agree with this guy and i started
laughing
because i forgot i said it and oh it's
funny because it gels with my
my personality and my sense of humor
because it's me dude
that's why it's because it's me
it's like the past me speaking to the
present me when i forgot about the [ __ ]
cross economy
hurts nobody
benefits everyone cross economy
here it is guess what it grows
so [ __ ] absolutely [ __ ]
first of all to say guess what
is there's honestly no non-cock way to
say that
guess what oh here we go
dude and then to follow it up
with a whisper to
a [ __ ] large audience
that is the most [ __ ] guess what i mean
imagine you're at a [ __ ] house party
and and the lady there is like i me i
made
these scalloped potatoes and you're like
guess what i like scalloped potatoes
you'd be like okay man chill
did you drive a lamborghini here
guess what scalloped potatoes are my
favorite
just so dick like
thought he thought that you know that
meme of all the [ __ ] dudes like this
like
or you know when a [ __ ] dude dunks a
basketball and
the one dude fake holds everyone else
back oh
you know who are they holding each other
back from what's that happening
nobody's holding the [ __ ] back i'll be
the i'll be the guy that that
i'll be the guy that does the outrage
you guys stand back
when somebody does a slam dunk you guys
hey the rest of the [ __ ] jazz
you guys stand back uh behind my arms
i'll do the one that's surprised oh
guess what slam the basketball
benefits the jazz hurts the hornets
dude it's amazing guess what
it grows the economy benefits everybody
hurts nobody said that last part louder
because the guy coughed and he got so
pissed off
hurts nobody guess what
crush economy somebody said i put on
tick tock i said what do you guys hear
and somebody said crows encounter me
and i [ __ ] laughed but i love that
[ __ ] and then i love
also presidents are just they're all
funny man like and then there was this
one
last president uh
donald trump this [ __ ] dude
no russia did not help me get elected
you know who got me elected
you know who got me elected i got me
elected russia didn't help me at all
russia if anything i think helped the
other side
what you ought to ask is this do you
think the media
helped wow just goes on and on
no russia didn't help me get elected you
know who helped me
you know who got me elected and then
double cocked it dude
he was so excited that was his guess
what because you can use a guess what or
you can feel a guess what right
if you're very confident you could just
feel the guess what that's what trump
was doing
but i didn't it needed to guess what all
good dude he needed to guess what
cross economy trump
didn't need the guess what he just
double cocked the question
you know who got me elected you know who
got me elected
he just did you know who got me elected
you know who got me elected
i got me elected
[Music]
that's so great dude guess what
come on oh color wheel i love when the
computer gets [ __ ] up
yeah dude dynamite man
guess what it grows the economy
benefits everybody hurts nobody
it's great it's great and you can't make
me not laugh at that
i laugh at whatever i want to
sometimes i show [ __ ] to my dad and
he'll just be like i don't get it
that's fine that's what being a son's
all about you take the next generation
of what's funny and you bring it to the
forefront
one time when i was a kid my dad
said i said to my dad dad do you like
this song don't remember what song it
was but it was a song
for me i was about 10 years old and it
was song for me and my friends
and he said no i don't like it and i
said how could you not like that and he
said it's just different when you grow
up
there's going to be songs out there and
they're just going to be like and i
remember
he made this noise he went
and i was like no there's not you really
think so and he said probably
and there [ __ ] are dude you ever
heard of dead mouse
uh but there wasn't that back in 1992
or 1988 89 probably
my dad was on some phil collins [ __ ]
[ __ ] lead singer slash drummer is
there a more
boss thing then
when you're in a band see that's some
real [ __ ] dude
you're either you're all that singer's
either just the singer
or the guitarist there's never really
been a singer doing anything else
maybe they'll do the a singer and
playing the piano
but phil collins was like oh no no no
he's british right or no is he no no
no no no he goes like this no
no no i'll play the drums and i'll be
the [ __ ] lead singer
and they're like but you have to
you're not going to be back there he's
like i'll figure it out and he just
rocked
i want i'm i'm jealous that he did that
because i wanted to be the first guy
ever to do that
and now i can't i'll be the guy who
[ __ ]
no only if i could play drums because i
like to be difficult baby i like to be
difficult man
but you know so many [ __ ] things
happen where um i like
you know i'm just i'm
i'm i'm right about things so it's fine
kristen kristen was like there was one
part in rick and morty that happened the
other night where rick [ __ ] was i was
i i get so many comments hey this guy's
the real life rick sanchez so i'm like
all right all right you know what you
win
internet i'll watch it i'll watch rich
rick and
i'll watch richard and morty i watch
rick and morty even though i'm like a
family guy guy
you understand i'll watch rick and morty
never seen it maybe i see one or two
episodes turned it on
it's so [ __ ] of course it's so good
it's so funny dude
and uh i'm like
i'm like i don't really understand why
it's because it's like he's complaining
about everything or he always thinks
he's right
and chris is like yeah and i'm like okay
that is
kind of me but then there was this one
part where he tells
morty to [ __ ] change hit the light
switch and he's like
hit the light switch on the right on the
right on the right
hit the light switch on the right and
then morty and then you hear morty go i
got it and you hear it
and then you hear another light switch
and he was like
what was that noise before the light
switch and he was like oh i don't know
and he was like it sounded like there
were two lights
and i'm like and dude i was dying dude i
was laughing so hard rolling around
and i look over kristen is not laughing
and i'm like why are you not laughing
and she was like honestly
it's funny but it's annoying because
it's like frustrating me because it's
like reminding me of times i was
frustrated about you
and i was like oh [ __ ] yeah i guess
you're right man i guess you're right
uh morty was [ __ ] there dude
rick was right you can easily
that's what we have is our language
that's all we have is our language dude
if you're not firing on all syllables
with your language
then what are we doing dude
it's like when you're like what did he
say and you tell them
generally what somebody said and then
you're like okay
is that as good as you could remember or
is that exactly what he said
and they're like i don't know it's like
it was exactly what he said and you're
like
dude do you not know or is it exactly
what he said because he said both
and they're like i i i think it was what
he said i'm not asking if you think i'm
asking you if that's exactly what he
said
or if you have the general idea of what
he said and you're relaying that to me
yeah okay i get it i get it i get it
it's rick and morty
but i believe that [ __ ] and we all [ __ ]
up but one time dude
i was i was sitting i was watching tv
with kristin and i was like
this is what that person just said on tv
and she was like no they said it the
other way and i said i know for certain
that this is not what they said
and we replayed it and she was right and
i was wrong and then i realized it was
only because of the way they cut it on
the tv
all good dude all good it wasn't my
fault it was the editor's [ __ ] fault
dude
it was her fault too for dragging me
into it it sucked
whoa got out of that one i love getting
out of him dude i love getting out of
them
whatever man it's hot and it's all good
what did he say [ __ ] what was the
thing he said
you know who got me the election you
know who got me the election i got me
the election
absolute [ __ ] absolute [ __ ]
takedown
i love this [ __ ] about how everyone at
star wars fans are getting upset about
the backlash for removing
there's a backlash from removing the
word the name slave one
first of all star wars called boba
fett's ship
slave one
so it's like you should have known in
[ __ ] 30 years you were gonna get in
some [ __ ]
slave one dude
but and now people of like star wars
who cares dude just who cares
this is the other thing too they're only
changing the name
because they think it hurts their bottom
line they don't give a [ __ ]
about anything but their bottom line
whatever it is disney or whatever
it says in the right here star wars fans
are outraged again over a decision to
remove the slave
one name from one of the iconic space
cruisers
disney has quietly dropped the moniker
because they know they're not gonna sell
if they call it the slave one
right but that is not the thing that i
think is hilarious
the thing that i think is hilarious is
that there are people who are mad at
this and doing stuff like this like this
guy tweeted boba fett
actually his handle is boba fett
a-n-h-s-e
mark anthony austin you'll always be
slave one to me
and like okay
like
they don't imagine the people at disney
seeing that tweet how little of a [ __ ]
they give
if you call it the slave one they don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
just being like yeah okay you call it
whatever you want we're just not going
to do it because it hurts our bottom
line we're in the business of making
money not naming [ __ ]
hyper devoted star wars fans are
notorious for causing a stink over
revisions and updates to their beloved
brand dude
dorks
just dorks who cares
call it [ __ ] hippie dippy i don't
care all right well
and then imagine tweeting well i'm still
calling it to say the slave one
oh that's nice for you and your family
bro
you know it just makes me laugh back to
when we
in the 80s it was like so now it was
like just so cool like it was like the
the just we were all just living and
just having a good time no one was
getting offended we were nobody had the
internet we were just in the meantime
you're
one of the [ __ ] people on this
internet that is causing the [ __ ]
outrage that's making everything
annoying
stop tweeting your [ __ ] problem and
just write a goddamn letter to disney
you know
uh yeah this is a problem i'm tweeting
it i'm not gonna call up my [ __ ]
i'm not gonna call up the person i got
their number but [ __ ] it
tweet no i'm still calling it slave one
it's just like guess what
slave one
calling it slave one benefits everybody
it hurts no one
dude this new [ __ ] mark wahlberg
movie came out i gotta see it
because it's mark wahlberg it's called
infinite of course
and ch chiwitel ego four
is in it is that guy that's that name
huh
that's like one of those names where
it's like oh here are the letters you
pick it
you you designed the name and like some
five-year-old was just like chewatley g4
you know like chad jacobson was you
could have made chad jacobson what
you are an infinite of course he is
let's watch this preview
you are an infinite wow
all starts with a guy driving a
motorcycle off of a [ __ ] cliff
okay i'm in dude i'm a hundred percent
in you want me to watch a goddamn movie
start with a guy driving a motorcycle
off of a cliff that was obviously in
ireland and i am
in
and and then go to something quiet right
a guy just a guy just kind of
sauntering in even macaulay
diagnosed with schizophrenia oh
[Music]
so ridiculous so far
a guy drives off a cliff
in a motorcycle and then the next thing
is a guy sauntering into a room with a
[ __ ] samurai sword saying to another
guy
you've been diagnosed with schizophrenia
uh sir nyu short film
[Laughter]
at 14. at 14. after carving the words
look inside this is the worst when when
i dude
this is movies this movie may be good i
have no idea i'm just tearing apart this
[ __ ] trailer
dude movies where a guy tells
another guy all about that guy [ __ ]
suck
it's like vanilla sky at the end of the
vanilla when the movie was so good
and then the end of the vanilla sky tom
cruise is like what the [ __ ] going on
what the [ __ ] going on everyone
watching the movies like what the [ __ ]
going on and then it gets stuck in an
elevator with some jackass that's like
this is what's been going on the whole
time and this is what's happening and
we're like now
so i could have just watched this scene
i could have just watched only this
scene
you had me watch two hours of [ __ ]
guessing and some guy was just gonna
show up in a suit and elevator all
cramped up and explain it to me
that's not cool dude i invested time
don't tell me i'd rather leave the movie
thinking what the [ __ ] was that all
about
then oh that guy said it okay i get it
don't spell it out i got google i can
look it up later
don't tell me be like david lynch dude
david lynch will just be like [ __ ] it
i'll put a guy with a big head in
it do your chest
with a box cutter i mean dude inside
hold on inside into your chest
after carving the words look inside into
your chest
sit and where you should look inside
why those words what's in the script
which one of these is yours
look you could skip the whatever the
hell this is
again with the [ __ ] ticking clock
i'll decide at what pace
i want my [ __ ] palms to get sweaty
don't add tic tacs
because your movie isn't
fire don't add
don't add the ticks of a clock because
your
movie isn't
hot stepping you understand
i'll decide when my palms get sweaty
we've already agreed that music could be
in it i don't even get i don't even like
that sometimes when the music swells and
you're like okay here we go
here come the bad guys i want the bad
guys to come when they come i don't want
to know when the bad guys are coming
i don't want the [ __ ] to be telegraphed
i don't want spooky [ __ ]
i don't want that
don't scare me with sounds
but they got the [ __ ] ticking clock
just like the karen movie that's mine
was it yours i don't know what you're
talking about anyway
uh what is ever i don't know what you're
talking about i'm not oh
jesus don't pull a gun on me
time you say i don't know this trigger
guess poop it's there's so much easier
ways to do this
you know every time you say i don't know
i pull the trigger to your head like
dude okay
look hey relax okay i want to be in one
of these situations in real life
so badly so i can just be like okay
look you've seen too many movies i get
it
i've got whatever you think i've got i i
don't believe i have this
let's both sit down there's a coffee
bean and tea leaf down the street
we'll go grab a [ __ ] i like black ice
americano you might know that i don't
know if you listen to my podcast
but i'll get you whatever you want and
let's hash this out like some [ __ ]
gentlemen because
you walking in with a [ __ ] sword into
this
dark dimly lit room with a bunch of fake
fog in it
and you think i don't hear the ticking
you're trying to elicit a response from
me and you're not going to get it okay
you will get it if we can just sit down
and have a good time dude let's talk
about stuff
likes and dislikes
i want to be in one of these situations
because what would happen honestly if
you sat down
and the and and and or you were in this
room that you were being kept in
and a guy put down three items and he
was like which one of these is yours and
you just go like this
i farted
you'd [ __ ] the guy up i mean that that's
like a [ __ ]
cell phone scrambler he'd be like and
that's when you flip the table up
and you do a [ __ ] uppercut and a spin
kick and you're out of there dude you
grab the machete and you run
well the thing is i don't really
recognize these three things but the
good thing is i
farted none of them are mine but you
know what is
and he says what and you look at him and
and you and then you just hear
i don't recognize any of these three
things i don't think any of them are
mine
but you know it is mine what
pinch your nose
look i don't know are you out of your
mind yes
last chance evan is
this yours
he remembers hello old friend oh and
they're friends dude
and then a car [ __ ] breaks for the
wall
get in get in of course
who breaks through a [ __ ] wall in a
car gets out and doesn't say
get in you could do it to [ __ ] close
to mcdonald's
at like [ __ ] 1am i'd still scream get
in
who wrong just a [ __ ]
the ronald mcdonald sketch statue get in
just screaming to it
now he's chasing him i mean how many
walls are they driving through
oh let me guess they go in the air yep
they go in the air see there we go
on june 10th a big library with a bunch
of books of course
evan sir nyu
short film this isn't your first life
evan the guy's name is evan make his
name more grand obviously
evan dude like you wear some [ __ ]
dockers and a [ __ ] button down
which one of these are yours we have
[ __ ] the carnation pink shorts
we have a polo shirt and then we have
some dark martins
i don't recognize any of these
i will put this cigarette out
on your blonde head if you do not
i don't know who they are oh what are
you [ __ ] crazy
the doctors aren't mine
ah i don't know
you are an infinite
you've lived
[Applause]
and died
a thousand times that's not infinite
you're talking about reincarnation yeah
man you know
if you can remember oh nice ferrari
oh my god if you can remember who you
were what do you think it is at the end
then you will finally know who you are
or some [ __ ] like that you know
if you can remember who you were
you will now know what you are supposed
to be
if you can remember who you were you
will
you will know now where you are going
if you can if you could remember evan
yeah you will understand
who you who you can become yeah dude of
course
you will know who you can become evan
even though your name will still be evan
basically you will know how much of your
daddy's money you could have
um oh [ __ ] it's on dude it's been on
my fan he's like turn your fan on it's
been on dude it's hot as [ __ ]
i'll turn it up one though i don't know
dude you know it's like
they just keep making these movies and
[ __ ] and now they don't even
are people even going to the movie
theaters anymore i don't even know
i don't even know but it's like my man i
used to [ __ ] be like oh i want to be
in movies because i want to be in a
movie that comes out the movie theater
that's not even happening anymore
there's this guy dude there's this guy
that i love
this was hilarious to me there was a
young man in in calvary
uh his name was ben okay and i was
running youth
i was there for a few years preacher and
um
he was a nice kid he was one of those
kids that was always just he's a real
smart aleck okay he was just was was a
bright kid
which didn't help things right made him
more dangerous right right
and we were outside one day youth group
and uh he was just
just trying to push my buttons and he
was just you know kind of not taking the
lord serious
[Music]
kind of not taking the lord serious he's
pushing my buttons and kind of not
taking the lord serious
is he calling himself the lord hey dude
you're pushing my buttons you're not
taking the lord serious i don't think
the lord gives a [ __ ] about this guy's
buttons but
maybe i'm going to hell and i walked
over to him and i went
bam i punched him in the chest not cool
absolutely not cool i crumpled the kid
assault crumpled him and i said
i leaned over and i said ben when are
you going to stop playing games with god
i led that man to the lord right there
oh there's times that that might be
this guy is infinite unbelievable he was
a young man in calvary
watch us again his name was ben and i
was running youtube i was there for a
few years
and um he was just he was a nice kid he
was one of those kids that was always
just
he's a real smart aleck he was just was
was a bright kid
feeling it didn't help things right made
him more dangerous
dang we were outside one day youth group
and uh he was just
just trying to push my buttons and he
was just you know kind of not taking the
lord serious
and i walked over to him and i went bam
i punched him in the chest as hard as i
i crumpled the kid
i just crumpled them and i said
i leaned over and i said ben when are
you gonna stop playing games with god
hey man are were you a kid when this
happened
or are you an adult bragging about
punching a [ __ ] kid
cause don't say that
arrest this guy that's like those
[ __ ]
when they should do those documentaries
about the [ __ ] the gang land [ __ ]
and they're just like it's just like a
plain old gangster just like without his
face scrambled and he's just like
yeah i killed like six six people in my
day and and you're just like
get em you know what i mean
like the document imagine filming that
you're just it's like we went to the
toughest neighborhoods found the
illest gangsters and we got in
undercover and we
and then there's this here we are
sitting with [ __ ]
[ __ ] loke and he's just like man i
killed like six seven people
back in my day and um
imagine rip shooting that the
documentary did the camera start shaking
and [ __ ]
the boom guy just
y'all [ __ ] no um well if yeah i ate
something it's not cause i'm nervou
nervous get him
you aired it on tv so brazen
the most brazen
i wanna why can't can one of those guys
come on this podcast and can i interview
him
so how'd you kill the first guy why
don't they [ __ ] do that in those
shows
oh whoa whoa stop right there dude this
documentary is
now not about your gang anymore
it is about solely you who was the first
guy that you killed
thomas okay and when was that
1986 and why i don't know man just [ __ ]
them
okay okay boom guy
y'all [ __ ] no no no no um
i ate nacho supreme from and the twisty
cinnamon things from taco bell
damn those are fire huh who was the
second guy you killed jared
why i don't know [ __ ] them
camera just shaking out of focus
can't wait till this [ __ ] comes out
why was it not yeah i killed six or
seven
what was the next thing you didn't hear
freeze
dude what are these gang how did the
how does that happen the gangs are like
yeah come on in you could do a
documentary on us
you're doing some uh so much bad
behavior
this right here this the gun because he
ain't got no serial number on it
uh got him he's wearing a handkerchief
it's fine just take it down you'll know
i don't understand am i missing
something i don't know
let's watch this i might cut it out
because somebody texted it to me
even though they know they're not
supposed to take a place of honor in our
hearts for you lord
we know that we can't receive anything
from anyone until we have
honor in our hearts for them first of
all i don't know what this is
it's rick pino who i don't know that is
but obviously he's also the lead singer
of smash mouth because that's what he
looks like and he couldn't look more
like the guy from [ __ ] flavortown or
whatever it is
first worst audio recording of all time
just like moses yeah
as a sign of honor
as a sign that you are removing the
things that separate you from the holy
place
i just invite you to kick off your shoes
right now kick off your shoes
okay come on everybody all over this
place i don't care how young you are i
don't care how old you are
kick your shoes off in this why does
that have to do with age that's so funny
he's just using like buzz catch phrases
i don't care how young you are or how
old you are kick off your shoes
not hard no matter what age you are
i don't care how young you are or how it
doesn't matter if you're black white
asian kick your shoes off
male or female alike these guys say so
many words
because they're their [ __ ] is such
[ __ ] these [ __ ] preachers
is such [ __ ] that they have to feel
so much space
that they just start doing these buzz
catch phrases which is basically what
this podcast does too
and while you're down there grab a
couple socks
it's insecure wow
come on didn't even finish the word on
everybody gonna grab
something to spin
this guy's on complete acid is this a
preacher
this guy is on adam you guys ready this
guy literally put a sheet of acid
in his [ __ ] like tucked it in his
socks
and then it rained and now he just
thinks he's orange juice
go ahead guys come on put those things
up
spin your shoes suck keys i don't care
you don't care everybody you're not
spinning anything
come on grab something everybody
[Music]
is insecure how he laughs yeah wow send
secure the yeah
[Music]
i sing this you spin
me right round jesus oh we're done
we're done dude
you spin me right round jesus right
round
just i didn't even
try yeah
you spin me right round jesus ride round
dude did it even try yeah
didn't add the word in the right place
malfunctioning religious bot dude
malfunctioning religious bot
you spin me right round jesus right
round
religion dude i am a preacher
you spin me right round jesus ride round
dude so [ __ ]
we'll create him to look like one of
them
we will create him he will have spiky
hair and shave the sides of his hair
we will put him in something that you
can definitely buy
at pacsun
and we will give him cool songs
but add jesus you spin me
right round jesus right round
you lift me jesus up
you raise me jesus up
jesus just wants to have fun
oh jesus just wants to have
that's all really jesus wants
is some jesus
dude this guy's a [ __ ]
what's up why are they swinging their
socks dude
just thinks he's orange juice add a
sheet of plastic
in his socks and it rained
round round taking so many liberties
dude
wow this guy spit me right round jesus
right round back
dude this is unbelievable
you spin me right round jesus ride round
dude this is unreal dude
oh hey now he's just let's sing this so
insecure let's sing this
no oh my god dude
you spin me right round jesus right
round like a record jesus round that's
what he did
adding the words at the wrong time did
you work on this
all you had to do was replace some of
the [ __ ] replace record with jesus
don't say jesus end record
unbelievable this guy dude
what's the [ __ ] song
um
the smash mouth on i don't know [ __ ]
also this song dude
this song of all the songs
little bit louder oh my god dude
sang little bit louder absolutely took
liberties
little bit louder dude that's a mate
this guy is
[ __ ] amazing he's invited to my
[ __ ] house you are invited
rick pino that's a guy's name you're
invited to my house dude
oh my god dude no doubt this guy for
real [ __ ] hookers
there's just no question there's no
question
so many liberties dude
[Music]
the mortal kombat song finish him
finish jesus him
[Music]
baptize him
[ __ ] yeah dude [ __ ] yeah dude
so closeted that guy for real
we're having a holy ghost hold on
wow dude how did that part happen i
skipped ahead
[Music]
hold down wow dude
backstreet's back jesus all right
everybody jesus yeah
out jesus body
yeah jesus everybody
back jesus streets back tonight
[Music]
wow that guy's killing everything he's
doing so many notes
[Music]
what's this one
i mean dude so many songs scream
everybody
you know it's so annoying this guy's
just screaming everybody
a little bit louder
honestly this is insane that this guy
did this but he's invited to my house
free open invitation come on over rick
pino let's look up rick pino
rick let's look up brick pinot grigio
right now dude
rick pinot grigio rick pino
here we go
oh he's got long hair now he's got rocks
is he religious dude he did something
that
he's not religious anymore
gotta go has to be is rick pino still
religious
oh no he still is huh conversation of
worship
rick pino leads 12 oh he's a worship
coach
hey friends what's up it's rick pino
here i'm excited to share this broadcast
with you uh to give you a little bit of
context so
he looks so much better like this all
the the virus and the quarantine's
broken out
to gather people from our movement for
those who don't know my wife and i we
founded a worship and missions movement
about six years ago called
okay i love this guy seems like the
nicest guy in the [ __ ] world
in all honesty
and now i feel bad that i made fun of
him um
but you spin me right around
you don't have to make the jokes dude
this [ __ ] is real it already happens
dude i took um
uh we took [ __ ] uh
calvin to the dude it's so cute man
we took calvin calvin 16 months now and
we took him to uh kristen was like we
made a
i made an appointment for him to go to a
uh
my gym or some [ __ ] and i was like
where we going he does like gyms
gymnastics and
she was like if you want to come i was
like if i wanna come
are you out of your [ __ ] mind
i'm gonna go the night before and sleep
there
like dude i would never miss that
and she was like okay cool so we got up
and we went
and we and we took him and it was so
[ __ ] cute dude
he walked in he didn't know what was
going on he's 16 months and you know
there were other kids that were like 15
months
i don't think anybody was even two i
mean they were like one
all of them were one they were like nine
one year olds
and they were just he was in there
and uh
we we made a circle and he sat on
mom and i was next to him they were like
we don't usually have two parents do it
because of covid but you know what this
is a small class so why don't you go in
and
i went in and he was just like looking
around and it was so
cute dude and there was one part where
the one of the instructors was like okay
come on
buddy everyone line up and we're gonna
get into
this sled and i'm gonna pull you around
and calvin would put him in the little
sled
and the guy was pulling and pulling him
around and calvin was just like sitting
in the sled just like
going all around and then [ __ ]
i cried dude because i was just like
he's growing up so fast and i cried
and um kristen
oh and then you know calvin was seeing
balls everywhere it's a ball ball paw
pal he went
went over to grab was going running to
grab a ball and another dad
[ __ ] beat him to it grabbed the ball
and [ __ ] threw it the other way
and i [ __ ] needed if there was ever a
time i needed rick pino dude
to just chill me the [ __ ] out and center
my religious soul
and to spin me right round jesus right
round
it was in that moment because i was
gonna [ __ ] catch a body dude
i was gonna catch a body or he was gonna
catch a body somebody was gonna wind up
dead
but i centered myself crystally is a new
person
plus kristen was there looking at me we
both gave each other the eyes like wow
can't believe that guy [ __ ] did that
but that's part of life and calvin will
learn that about [ __ ]
and then somebody took a toy out of
calvin's hand and the mom
was like no you don't do that and then
calvin went to go
grab the toy back and we're like calvin
we share
that's how you do it
dude discipline those [ __ ] for
real i'm gonna disap i can't
calvin hasn't really [ __ ] up yet can't
wait can't wait can't wait till he [ __ ]
up
because i'm going to be scary dude i'm
going to be like
until he's like just kidding
but we don't do that again right because
maybe dad's a demon
no we don't know i'm telling you i'm not
and i'm very nice you've only
experienced me in a nice way
but don't do that again because
oh you're about to cry but look dad's
back
so we don't do that again because we
don't want dad's inner demon to come out
do we
because i'll tell you right now if you
keep doing that a demon pops through his
chest
no more dad just a red being that lives
with your mother
from now on just a red being that lives
and he's a lot shorter than dad he's
about this big he's about [ __ ] two
and a half feet tall it's really scary
and all he eats are [ __ ] all he eats
are your cheerios so do you really want
that
do you really [ __ ] want that
um yeah there's really creative ways to
discipline your kid i don't know why
people just
say no and then just the kid keeps doing
it and then they're like
you know no
no and they're like no and then the kid
keeps doing it and i mean i see it all
the time
no and the kid keeps doing it and
they're like all right i said no fine
that's my thing no we don't do that
at this household okay not for me i turn
into a being
um i'm sorry little kids hey guys that's
it for youtube if you want to catch the
rest of the episode you can join our
patreon that's patreon.comcrystalia
uh you catch the rest of this episode
and all the backlogs of the other
patreon episodes
that there are uh that number keeps
growing and growing so
check it out um thanks a lot
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
hey guys welcome to